welcome back to the show thank you for
joining us our special guest
comedian and social media troll extruden
extraordinaire
brent theriune brent welcome to the show
thank you for joining us how are you my
friend i'm well it's good to be here i
love what you've done with the place oh
yeah it's kind of nice
yeah i like what you did with your
garage there it looks like you built a
wall and you you built the wall and uh
yeah that actually this is all green
screens
it just comes crashing down
the moon is behind me because i'm on the
same set that they did the moon landing
on that would be so hilarious
if these people actually believe that
like everything behind any any
quote-unquote liberal is a green screen
and george soros is sitting it's like
the man behind the curtain action
and it's all like one big one it's all
like one big warehouse
he's an old-timey director like we're
doing it on film you see
he's like 120 years old so of course
that's the kind of film you know the
film yeah yeah that he would use is like
the he's just you know what he's just
like he's recording over the jfk type
tapes he's like i got this
ah that's hilarious put it in the can
like that's where it comes from
so is that is that how you started like
some of the social media videos is like
the the the pandemic or was it before
that
before
like i was doing a problem like when
people know that the character the you
know that the truck rant character um
it i started really when kaepernick
started kneeling
um and i did that one initially and then
a year later he got the contract with
nike and that one really popped so
um and then but i was doing videos
before being a dude from indianapolis
indiana nobody's really doing much for
you so the internet is the equalizer
you know let's put stuff out there and
you know hopefully people see it right
you just [ __ ] all over the place and see
if someone will clean it up then yeah
against the wall and what sticks and
smear it you know yeah we all three are
from the same part of the country he's
from chicago you're from indy i'm from
central missouri like we can almost
throw a stone at the places that we're
from so we understand all these you know
these midwest type things right like and
and that's really part of like your
satire is this this goofy doofus from
the midwest right not really
not really red i mean i guess it is kind
of redneck i mean i know a lot of
hillbillies right because i'm in ozark
so i know a lot of hillbillies which is
a specific
specific type of redneck but the midwest
field is a little different i would
break it like i would see like people uh
tend to lump in white trash hillbilly
i think those are three different types
of people absolutely you know like it's
you could break it down by what they
drive like a
white trash is like a trans am type guy
but you know with like two different
color fenders of course yeah yeah yeah
it's but then like a you know a redneck
or a hillbilly that's more of a truck
you know but then like hillbilly's like
a lifestyle as opposed to like redneck
is an attitude if that makes sense right
yeah yeah yeah yeah well i i know plenty
of hillbillies for sure i mean um i i at
some points in my life i is one right
like
like i'm from i'm from the ozarks i grew
up at the lake of the ozarks where the
netflix series ozarks is is shot yeah so
um i i is one at to some degree so i
agree with you that hillbilly's
definitely a lifestyle and redneck can
be an attitude because a hillbilly can
be a redneck is that what you're saying
and a redneck doesn't necessarily
they're not necessarily a hillbilly oh
yeah are you guys is this like a square
can be a rectangle but a rectangle can't
be a square
yeah absolutely 100 don't ask me to give
you more examples past the one i gave
you because
that premise might break down but you
know okay well you know what happens
well also you know the other thing about
a square in a rectangle you can fill in
a square direction or you can just do
the outline like that's kind of that's
kind of the situation when you're
talking about like white trash hillbilly
redneck and we can say all these things
because
we is them right yeah well you know i
asked my grandma to say wash because
it'll be wars right now like you get
that r in there so yeah that's
definitely in my uh
and my family some some redneck type
things have happened of course so well
you know you get close to st louis and
there's an r in toilet too they say
toilet yeah there's an r somewhere in
the closer you get to st louis
yeah there's an r in the toilet i don't
know where it's
a real toilet yeah the toilet you go
take a [ __ ] on the toilet
it is
bizarre like that r pops up everywhere
like it in boston you get the you know
uh
i saw it i saw it
and then but then you get a
in in indiana it's like that that
migrates across the country and pops up
where it shouldn't be right right well
there's ours everywhere i guess so so do
you say
soda do you say soda pop do you say pop
what what do you what what what does
your
and indy what do they say i've chosen to
be a serial killer and i call it cola
i've chosen the route that nobody takes
oh no one calls it [ __ ] cola but uh
who calls it like rc cola like oh man i
remember having rc cola at the gym after
like we'd have our grade school
basketball games they'd be like come the
concession channel and buy some snacks
and we've also got rc cola yeah like
what the [ __ ] is he cola it's it's flat
coca-cola
they also have fresca on tap as well oh
man
faygo i i've never seen faygo on tap
either there was a pla like bloomington
illinois there used to be a comedy club
there and i would i would go to the
restaurants and every one of the
restaurants had rc cola or their
products because they were like it's
cheaper than coke or pepsi so it was
just very bizarre like you see to even
see rc cola let alone every place around
there but i say uh soda my family will
say pop so that's i will i've chosen
soda because it's not my family i got
you i got you
well you know you know my mom she she's
from like uh northern missouri
south iowa but by illinois so right
around in that area they call it pop
exclusively like you're saying
but um some folks around there would
call it so d pop
so d-pop not soda sodie pop so in my
house when i was a kid my mom because we
didn't call it pop down where i'm from
in central missouri it's called soda but
my mom would say still say sody so in
our house it was you wanna sodi right it
wasn't the soda it was a sweet which
makes sense when people are like oh let
me take a road saudi right which is yeah
sure potentially taking an alcoholic
beverage but yeah road sodium is
taken on the go so i can see where sodi
comes from i don't know where it
originates from that phrase but sodi's
in that one but like i only i only call
it soda you know or or there's the oh
let me get a coke right but then coke is
universal to everything else focus yeah
what kind of coat is that southern thing
no it's not a southern thing though
isn't that a sudden like maybe i don't
know
i think it nowadays like it's a coke is
kleenex you know okay it's just that
brand name and then somebody had to tell
me i'm like kleenex is the brand name
i'm like i did i thought it was just
like jacuzzi jacuzzi is the is the
actual company right that's the brand
name but now everyone calls it
ping pong
it's table tennis
yeah oh really frisbee whoa whoa wait a
second wait a second
crock pot
don't nope wait wait crock-pot is a
brand new stop right there yeah
you are blowing mine right now hang on a
second are you telling me that the game
of ping pong
is not the game of ping pong that is a
brand name yeah and i'm also paid i
should full disclosure i'm paid by big
ping pong
so
you deep skater i meant
double check that but i think that's the
brand name is ping pong because
otherwise you have to say table tennis
well who who gives a [ __ ] we'll say it's
fact here we can we can say whatever we
want here we're on the we're on the the
matter what does it mean no if you say
it enough it's real so that's right yeah
exactly what would you say you say it
three times it becomes truth
oh is that right i don't know i mean but
if i say it two more times it is okay
good say it five times that's candy man
don't do that
speaking of truth and untruths on the
internet so
these videos that you did
you really kind of dig into like
the the trump supporter mentality and
what i mean by that is like you're not i
mean you you are making fun of them with
satire right and you are doing it as
parody and and these folks are really
getting more and more difficult to
parody at this point but when you're
doing when you're doing those characters
um it's it's almost and i felt like your
version of that
felt so authentic so like where
is it your family members is it your
friends is the people that are around
you the people because i've i i have
family members other trump supporters
i've lived in quote unquote trump
country my whole life like so this
trumpism thing isn't surprising to me um
you know and how it developed and where
it's at where did you get like where did
you get that character what is is it
someone you know or is it where is that
from it's just you know being living in
it i guess you know indiana's home of
mike pence uh and i live in indianapolis
but if you go a little bit out there's
it's not a city it's just
the country and people are like
certain states are all corn i'm like
i've driven across the country it's all
horn
but then you know doing shows in places
where you know it's uh you would say
it's a you're not from around here type
of town where it's like it's bob
seeger's turn the page you walk in and
everybody knows that you are the guy
for the show or you're you're the guy
that doesn't live there
and you could just if you listen enough
or you you drive past enough houses and
small towns and it's the flag still it
says trump won or i saw one one of my
favorites it's it was trump 2020 but
they crossed out the last zero and made
it a floor they didn't even buy a new
friend again you're expensive man the
grip is not cheap i mean yeah it's fun
it's like it's so weird how people
will just spend all this money on a dude
that doesn't care about them and and
like buy flags and all this like but you
if you drive around long enough you see
that stuff and you see i love a bumper
sticker
uh just any and if i see something that
has a bunch i try to get right up behind
it to see what it what's this person's
philosophy and they're like well that
doesn't make sense with that one and
that one you know like so you're like
case studying these people to to to
develop your
your repertoire as it were is that what
you're saying like it wasn't it wasn't
intentional at first but then you fought
you know you i follow a bunch of truck
rant guys because some of them
it's just
again like you said they're not doing
parody you're they're not doing parents
no
at a certain point you're like
how do you parody clown shoes
they're already big you know like
so you watch and then and then sometimes
you're like god damn it like how was it
this far but it is you know yeah yeah
i can definitely relate to that like
aspect of
like uh okay when i because you had a
video where i was drinking urine right
in the car yeah yeah and i think katie
couric even retweeted or quote tweeting
was like what did i just yeah i don't
remember it was her name but yeah she
didn't know that it was she didn't know
it was parody
as i said that was what i gathered it's
hard to tell when people share stuff
anymore if they're in on it or not but i
think she was like i don't remember what
she said exactly but it was like what
the hell question mark type thing or
whatever well like it's so it's to kind
of touch on the point that tony brought
up is like there is a there is a an
aspect of authenticity in there and
whether it's because the sunglasses and
and the beard and you're in the car and
you know that kind of situation where
people are like okay this seems like
this is like raw
yeah he just like went on some rant
um but people you know they like because
like any good story right you get the
hook in the first part where you're like
this guy's crazy what are you talking
about and then like
somewhere after the the halfway mark or
like the three quarters way through then
you reveal that oh this you know this is
so ridiculous this can't be real right
now obviously
every day like tony said
um
you
you get out done by reality right like
okay cool like i heightened it to here
and then tomorrow the news is like
actually that was reality and now this
is where we're at and then the next day
you're like [ __ ] okay uh okay let me
hide it here we're get to a point where
it's like everything's on fire all at
once and the only way to make it more
extreme is to
like it's hard to do that
and like for the for the urine example
that was one of those like well they
already are drinking urine like what's
the next step right in my the video that
i made i was like [ __ ] this is gonna
eat [ __ ] so it's a dude on the toilet
and he eats [ __ ] and some people online
were like this is insane are you kidding
me why would you do this and some people
are like oh this is hilarious
but it is very like we live in a reality
right now where it's like
is it real i don't know well you're not
getting if you're off you're not too far
you just wait a little bit and they
might be eating their own [ __ ] at this
point exactly it's one step further and
it's not that out of the realm of you're
already drinking urine so yeah right
well what what is the craziest thing
that you did a video about you're like
there's no this is the craziest thing
i've ever said and then months later
you're like oh my god they're actually
they're doing what i was saying is is
hilarious and funny and a joke i mean
was there something specific
i don't i wouldn't have to look back
because sometimes people will quote back
things that i said i'm like i don't
remember saying that
uh yeah i would have to look back
because and it's it is weird because you
could just kind of
you know
notice trends of here's how this will go
and then eventually somebody does that
thing and you're like and then it's not
like i'm like a great predictor you
could just kind of look at things and be
like this is how it was going to end up
anyway you know right this is the
cul-de-sac that they're running down
right yeah yeah right that they're just
going to do circles well i mean
[Music]
um
white privilege tonight he has a show
called white privilege tonight and they
were talking about woke's giving i
believe is what it was and then like not
but like a couple weeks later and i
forget who it was it might even been
like kaylee mcinanny or something no it
was it was marjorie taylor green oh was
it she said something about wokesgiving
is that what it wasn't it wasn't works
giving it was the phrase that we had
decided to use in the bit was uh
critical race training oh that's right
that and then margaret taylor green came
out just a few weeks after it was like
they got this critical race training and
we're like
and like we did the parody of that thing
like weeks before yeah just it's crazy
that that
like you said you're not predicting
anything but you do see where this the
stupidity is headed right like that's
what makes the satire and parody
sometimes
difficult and and gabe i know finds it
very difficult sometimes to find because
he'll he'll he'll text me like his
script sometimes he's like is this far
enough do you think this is
like like is it am i going one step
further enough or am i gonna be behind
by the time i post this thing yeah
either too gabe where it's like is this
even is this
not even parody it's just me rewriting
what they said you know yeah you're like
is this is this funny i don't know like
have i heightened it to a point where
like okay
this is an exaggeration and then of
course you know sometime down the line
you're like well that's news now like
that's what it's been said to why i mean
i mean for the the queen of destroying
parody was sarah palin they took her
words and they put it on saturday night
live and the whole country thought it
was hilarious and like that's actually
what she said like that if you watched
the interview
she literally said she could see russia
from her house right it's crazy it's
crazy stuff but you know maybe parody is
dead what do you think do you think
parody and satire is is dead or do you
think there is hope for revival of
this art form that you
so greatly do
uh no i don't i don't think it's it's as
long as there's something to parody you
cannot there are there will always be
parody but it again it's like i think
the guys from south park were like
again it was kind of what we just talked
about of like what whatever they write
something crazier happens
before they even get the episode out so
and that i don't i don't know when that
stops because at a certain point
something will happen and you know one
side or the other will have a take where
you're like did you even have to say
anything about this opinion like you
don't we don't
like one side automatically has to be
against it and one side has to be for it
and you're like nobody really even cared
about this thing so i don't know why you
were even talking about it you know but
it's like everybody has to have an
opinion on everything and sometimes you
don't need to have an opinion on things
you know
speaking of things that happen and have
an opinion and and not knowing where
people are going to stand because norman
like you're saying you know exactly
who's going to say what and what they're
going to say about whatever the the
incident or the news is
what i found interesting about a will
smith uh chris rock moment is like it
actually like destroyed all of that
right like i think that's why it went so
i mean other than the fact that will
smith went on stage and [ __ ] slapped
uh chris rock which is which was his
right no
oh heard it here first
oh so you're going to take that you know
and honey
well i mean i mean
you can give us our take of that moment
we've seen uh i think it was last night
and at the what is it called the
hollywood bowl is that what it's called
hollywood bowl yeah yeah it was the
netflix is a joke right festival and uh
someone came up on stage and and tried
and i think they kind of tackled dave
chappelle um but his security
literally turned him into a pretzel i
don't know if you've seen the video of
the pictures but the dude is he's [ __ ]
up yeah i mean uh to the point to where
he's probably gonna have to have a lot
of surgery to fix his boneheaded move
where he thought it was a good idea to
go on stage and try to tackle dave
chappelle so i mean from going from that
moment and like the whole everyone
taking their position
and now you have this moment where dave
chappelle which has had his own
controversy now he's will smith in other
words
um hey how how do we put this in a box
how do you as a comedian
frame this up to make sure that you're
on the right side brent and you don't
get cancelled for the wrong
opinion because you know we have that
imaginary thing to deal with too just
don't be shitty don't move the person
can be an [ __ ] is that what yeah
that's
pretty easy and certain people will hate
you for certain things you said but if
you think you're you know if they're if
that's a good take in a moral position
to take then who cares if people hate
you to begin with you know
uh yeah and it's that's it like again i
think it that will smith thing and the
chappelle thing is an isolated incident
i don't think that's going to happen
across the i don't know unless you're a
guy that likes to poke the bear with
your your stand up or whatever i don't
i don't know how you guys feel about it
i just feel like
that all those now those two incidents
have blown up right but what if it was
anybody but chappelle would that have
happened i don't know so you say you
don't have people bum rushing the stage
to will smith you is that what you're
saying when you're doing your stand up
no one i don't have a lot if the that my
stand up is completely different from my
videos
i don't have a lot of hot takes oh okay
um
so you don't see you don't you don't
scorch earth the room is what you're
saying then no i'm i've never been a guy
that's like that's right i said it you
know
i said what i said and you all could go
[ __ ] yourself you should try opening
with that next time just like that just
like that's right i said it you're like
i didn't say anything what did you say
you said i will hold on
i want to open up with i'm going to
leave you with this
yeah i just leave yeah i think that's a
great i mean i would i would stand up
and be like that was some [ __ ]
multi-level [ __ ] right there i don't
know just do those two lines you could
just do those two lines and walk off and
i think they would be happy
i'm gonna leave you with this that's
right i said it
just yeah that's it that's all you need
that's all you need so so about your
stand up how long have you been doing uh
the stand-up comedy uh 17 years 17 years
you you are a veteran my friend well i
started in high school so as as a ch as
a we child but uh
yeah i just started when i was young and
uh you know
after college i was like i could get a
real job or do stand-up and so far so
good so if you can live with your mom
for a long time that always helps
so are you are you broadcasting from
your mom's basement or have you made
enough money in stand-up that you have
bought your own basement she lives in my
attic oh
i am uh i am broadcasting from my own
house thank you oh good good well i just
you know i i want to make sure of where
we where
yeah but if if anybody needs to to be
set up in my mom's place she'd be happy
to hook you up no
uh but it's like for a lot of that i was
a guy that you know if you live in the
midwest or not one of the major cities
it's like you work the road so
there was for you know pre-pandemic i
remembered i would do like 47 weeks of
staying up on the road places you know
so you didn't actually live at a house i
mean that's the thing is uh i if i was
paying rent on an apartment i wouldn't
have been there anyway so right yeah you
literally
yeah yeah oh that's nice it's nice and
warm and folded so you're saying you you
have like a ma there was a magic hamper
at your mom's house and you really
closed in and yeah and now that i'm
married 47 we went away so oh
love my wife she's great just a joke
everybody just just jokes just jokes not
not being too serious we wouldn't want
to we won't want someone to think these
are our actual opinions right yeah so
growing up growing up in indiana and
becoming a stand-up comedian like how do
you how do you go from knowing that hey
i'm funny
because i i've done some uh some open
mics we discussed that before we came on
the air and and stand up is probably
one of the most difficult performances
that there is i i think because i i've
done performances and i've done the open
mic and it is it is a very difficult
performance especially for like a
smaller audience at like an open mic
night
um you know the more people you have
laughing sometimes the easier it is to
get more people to laugh but
how do you go from knowing that that is
what you're going to do i think that is
a real question because there's a lot of
comics out there that move from stand up
to something else
maybe they work in film or movies or
writing how did you know like
i'm on the road 47 weeks out of the year
my mom has a magic camper that does my
laundry
and i want to do this for the rest of my
life like what is the moment that makes
that for 17 years
uh i remember
one of the like i guess epiphanies or
whatever i had it was like my first like
week i got to host
as a as a comic and it was like a
wednesday to sunday like a long
and i'm doing it was like the first time
doing more than like two shows in a week
and then doing more than 10 minutes
uh at a time and at the like that was my
goal was like i want to be able to host
and work a full week and then at the end
they gave me a check and i had forgotten
that i even would make money from that i
was like oh and you get money too
um so that was a thing
of like oh you can make money and this
this could be a job it depends you know
depends on
how good you are and even then
being funny is not even half of it it's
you know
no knowing who you know and all that a
lot of stuff has to happen
to fall in line for you even to to be
working anything not even a stand-up you
know um but it was like i get like that
thing in 2012 i'm like i finished school
i could get a job in radio which is what
i went for or i could get a real job
i don't have a job now so why don't i
try stand up
and so far so good you know and it
wouldn't be the car it could be the it
could be the car and then you just
become the you know the persona that
you've created on online yeah i've fully
just transformed everything
every full moon i just put on oakley's
and a backwards hat
and ran to the moon so so tell us about
these videos because some of my favorite
is the jump cuts that you do sometimes
in your videos um where you're doing the
jump cuts that editing that you do
because you're not you're not just doing
a rant you're editing these videos and
you're editing the way with the jump
cuts to make them interesting to keep
people through the video um because that
is one challenge with the internet is
you got to hold the people's attention
longer than two damn seconds so so how
do how do you like because i i've always
been interested in how gabe writes these
things because i don't write anything i
just i just start to talk and just
record it right so so how do you how do
you go like from your idea of okay this
is the subject that i want this is what
how i want to form it but this is how i
want it to look with the jump cuts quiz
because i find that always one of the
most hilarious things is the jump cuts
that you're doing because
theoretically these these trump
supporters that are doing the real
videos they're not really doing jump
cuts i mean they barely are holding the
camera correctly right yeah so how do
you how do you work that into the to the
laughs that jump cut thing
i mean maybe gabe you could testify to
this too but sometimes it's just out of
boredom to
let's change it up or right um or just
uh how do i not wear out my welcome you
know people like these videos but at a
certain point people be like okay this
guy's doing too much with whatever so if
i can keep it fresh or for me create
creatively you know sometimes the jokes
are funny but then if i can have a funny
cut and i'm somehow laying and uh like
my seat is fully reclined like
how far can i take this medium you know
like
and sometimes that's the that's more the
fun part is
if especially if it's like an evergreen
video as opposed to i gotta have a take
and i gotta have it now and it's gonna
come out right now
but sometimes it's more evergreen thing
of like if i could say nobody wants to
work anymore while on a swing
while having a plate of nachos on my
belly like an otter
like how many ways can i say this and
have it be funny you know right uh and
some of that is just
boredom and some of it is let's keep it
fresh for everybody right i've always
waited for brent to show up on one of
the jump cuts in the back dash of the
car like
i was wondering can he fit in the back
dash i've been in the back seat but now
that's the back the back part is the
final frontier oh okay
i'm not trying to give anything away
i've also wanted to surf like teen wolf
uh but that's that's dangerous i'd have
to have more than one person doing that
no just like ghost ride the whip you
know and then jump on and then post yeah
look whatever the outcome of the video
whether you you know aren't injured or
you are injured i think is
beautiful you know yeah yeah but i can
definitely relate to what you're saying
is like yeah you know not wanting to
feel like
it's the same bit again and again like
oh it's the same guy saying about the
same things right on this different
topic let me guess he hates the thing
he's talking about you know like that
kind of thing right right and you know
and you and here's the thing like
because like the characters that we
create like you try to find interesting
ways where it's like well maybe this guy
isn't entirely an [ __ ] like maybe
he's just like misunderstood like maybe
there are parts of that i can relate and
i can say oh you know what he's not so
bad right he he's misguided but he's not
a really bad person because everyone you
get you the the the flame of like this
guy's an [ __ ] and i ca i don't like
him because of these things like it
it'll die out real quick
if you
uh make a few videos you're like well
that just that's just a trump supporter
or like
that's just whoever this person is with
this really bad take on whatever it is
and it gets really old however if you
can add different elements whether it's
like
you know they go back in the recliner or
you're on the swing set or like you're
changing the environment or whatever it
is you learn you you grow the world and
you build this environment to be like
okay yeah this guy's interesting he says
some really dumb stuff but there is
something behind this guy that's more
than just like a rant here a rant there
and i think that does a lot whether it's
a jump cut because you're like oh i need
a quick transition to get someone's
attention or something to put you in a
different scenario or it is just like
the
the the unedited we'll say cuts of you
in one situation to another situation
you're like yeah this guy
doesn't have the greatest editing
abilities so he would just go from here
to down here to over there or whatever
it is so it's like there again i think
it goes back to
the authenticity
you you shitlibs are just trying to
humanize everything
trying to write a whole feature-length
film
but like in some of that too i love like
uh when the background is busy and that
a lot of that was my early ones were at
my mom's house
and it was i purposely wouldn't cut the
grass
for a long time and there's a privacy
fence so it's not like this video has
been four weeks in the making so your
[ __ ] neighbors are pissed at you for
this one video privacy fence so okay
okay okay yeah probably not happy but uh
like just have a bunch of [ __ ] in the
background like that my mom's garage was
that way before i i cleaned it up but it
was like just have it be busy yeah so
like you even have to look back and be
like is that you is that a unicycle
you know what the [ __ ] is a unicycle
doing in the team because it definitely
it adds way more to to the world where
you're like yeah like what is who who is
this guy why does he have that stuff you
know or people just you get clean your
garage comments or whatever
used to pump the algorithm just to pump
the algorithm
yeah you know you got to do what you can
do speaking of the algorithm and
comments so um i don't get a lot of the
whole
trumpers coming in and hating me
obviously i'm a white dude from the
midwest it sounds like i sound like so i
think that has a lot to do with it then
i don't get a lot of the hatred there
gabe has gotten a lot of hatred
what do you do you find the trolls
amusing or do you kind of mute the
trolls because there's a lot of trolls
on the internet like this is a this is
an ongoing i guess depending on how you
look at a problem or a helpful thing
like i think the trolls are helpful like
i love my trolls i i want them to bump
the algorithm and comment and fight and
he's got a big brush is coming the troll
hair
absolutely absolutely so how do you feel
about the internet trolls and and what
kind of pushback do you get for some of
your stuff speaking of that yeah i think
if you're going to be a troll at a
certain point just be entertaining
from for a guy who sees a lot of
comments and stuff
just if you know oh you're fat
yes
everybody knows
if you've ever posted anything on the
internet you mo you know more than
anybody
what they're about to say to you like
it's at a certain point oh you're fat
it's like
okay
we all know
please at least create say i look like a
fat version of black well like
you know
sometimes you're like you're not even a
like a good troll there's no creativity
and that's why you are a troll because
you're sad or whatever makes you happy
to comment on all these comments or what
are all these car
accounts or whatever but
i i think if you're gonna be a troll at
least be creative man right some of that
like you'll just see like a sponsored
facebook post and
you can tell the company chose that
person for whatever reason they've got
the weirdest eyebrows
or whatever and i just go to the
comments and i'm like let's see this
dude get roasted
let's see this person get roasted
but that's that's why the company chose
this person right for whatever feature
and i'm like
let's see how funny this is yeah you're
like i chose this woman because sex
sells i chose this dude for his eyebrows
crazy thousands of people are gonna open
this thread and gonna read every single
comment in the thread yeah that's that
you know that's not a bad marketing
strategy if you think about it um when
you are using the the algorithms in that
way because we we had we had a troll
this morning and said i think you said
your podcast sucks and i was like thanks
for tuning in
yeah you didn't even watch a video of
the internet you had to go to a place
right you're not even on main street you
walked down an alley
to tell me i said and then you came back
to give me your to give me your opinion
on the thing you went and seen and i was
like thanks for
thanks for watching i i mean that's cool
thank you that's trolling what just you
the thing you do sucks okay
like
you could yeah it's like you could be
creative you it was like maybe you're
working to the height of your
intelligence but i would hope that you
would at least offer something more than
this thing sucks
or you know your this or whatever it's
like yeah you know give me a comparison
make it interesting make me laugh like
come on don't just try to hurt my
feelings but make me cry and laugh at
the same time you're gonna do it yeah at
least let me be impressed with you you
know
yeah it's it is so that base level of oh
you you're dumb you're stupid but then
like people will hang around
for months
to tell you nothing that they haven't
already said like it's right great sure
if you want to do that it doesn't hurt
my feelings we love our hate watchers
speaking hate watchers that shout out to
our hate watchers out there we love them
we like as long as as long as you're not
going to say really racist or big [ __ ]
in our comments
we'll let you hang around and be it be
an [ __ ] like you said earlier like i
mean i occasionally i i occasionally get
the people who tell me to go back to my
country you know and i'm like well i was
born in chicago but all right yeah yeah
uh or people tell me to go back to my
old country buffet
see that's a good i just thought of that
right yeah right right yeah you just
started your way it changes the whole
thing right like people tell me like oh
i hope ice comes to get you and i'm like
for what
yeah like like can can we do a little
bit of research here guys like you i
know you're all about doing your own
research but like [ __ ] you could do a
better job of at least getting i've got
a lot of stuff on the internet you could
do a little bit of searching
to add a little bit of spice to it
i do love when somebody will incorrectly
attribute a stereotype to somebody else
like you didn't even try
[Laughter]
you know these jews are bad drivers like
like just like
you didn't even try you just
that's not even a real trope
like how did you mix this up this is
either yeah either scenario isn't real
but like how did you get one with the
other you know you're bad at just being
racist right right right right which is
a really horrible horrible attempt at
anything if you're just bad at being
racist because there's so many easy
things that you could that you couldn't
even be and that's a yeah it's a hard
thing it's like hey that person's a
racist that's like a whole another level
it's like you're just bad at being a
racist
like you really tried and you failed and
somehow i didn't even think was possible
yeah i do love people that are like
shout out to my haters and i'm like you
don't have haters
you just
need to move out of your mom's house or
whatever i'm talking about me but uh
don't don't listen to him folks shout
out to my haters
people that love that think that the
whole world is watching them and i'm
like it's only me and that's what i'm
here for you know
speaking of watching so you have a
podcast
um is it is it different than your
stand-up and your your social media
videos that you post or yeah i have two
different podcasts one i i do weekly
it's with uh john now easy easy we only
get one plug per but
i'm just kidding i'm just kidding no go
ahead go ahead i'll upgrade to the
premium version of this
sounds
good good good the paid version
it's uh called the cafeteria and it's a
general chat show if you tune in for a
certain topic we really we just kind of
talk so you're like the fourth member of
our friendship it's johnny laquasto who
is a stand-up he's a just a tv host but
then
uh he was like an announcer for wwe he
does boxing commentary that kind of
thing excuse me and then the other guy
is named ryan knee miller who he's a
stand-up he got third place on america's
got talent but he is the crippled threat
of comedy and those that's his title not
mine uh
no no canceling brent for the the title
it's not how he's dubbed himself so
that's weekly and then i do one called
the field trip which is topic based
stuff uh like famous last words
or uh parody religions stuff like that
where it's like you know emily
dickinson's last words were
uh i must be going into the fog or
something i'd have to look it up but
it's like that's for a poet that's the
most poetic thing i've ever heard you
know right or one a guy on a firing line
was like scoot up boys it'll be easier
[Laughter]
do you do you pick the topics or does
your audience pick the topics and then
you you're like i'll go with this one
this week yeah i usually pick them uh
but i've i've had suggestions too that
i'll take but like then we've had like
the worst roommate stories
or whatever so it's it's you know if you
don't like that topic i'll have a new
one next week but it's usually just uh
no not not con no consequence
fun talk it's not anything
groundbreaking you know
or uber facts well i like the the
the company uber or like oh oh the
twitter account uber yeah yeah so and i
think it's like i think we're about to
do it but uh trivia stuff but it's like
if it's on uberfax
no question that is a fact
and we just talk about it so i don't
question it if it's on uber you just
accept
yeah it's like a random fact generator
and it's a you know it takes you to
weird places sometimes speaking of facts
in weird places you you alluded that
we're going to play trivia here we like
to wait it's been a while since we've
had a uh an extended post post interview
here where where gabe does his his magic
on editing um but we like to play trivia
with our guest and i i've been looking
forward to playing trivia with you i
actually prepared some um very good
questions normally have like multiple
choice i did not do this this time
i found a great website that had some
really weird funny questions i don't
even know if they're really true but
we're going to ask them anyways and see
what you guys come up with because you
and gabe are going to play
trivia so let's start
[Music]
all right are you ready it's ready as i
can be okay okay so here's here's here's
the thing because we have a lot of good
tech here
rent so it's it's high tech so um when i
ask the question to answer you ring in
by giving a thumbs up so it's very high
tech um cool okay that sound good all
right so we'll do as many questions as
you guys want because these are [ __ ]
fantastic question number one and by the
way there is no winner and you're not
you're not going to win anything so i'm
going to decide by the way
he's going to hold it over my head in
class he's just going to be like right i
beat gabe and trivia yeah
seed partners with loser gabe
okay so trivia question number one in
california
you can't legally buy a mouse trap
without having what
mustache
why a mustache is there a particular
reason why you picked a mustache it
seems like you know crazy law that you
would
you must be mustachioed on a sunday
okay well that is incorrect
correct that's crazy the correct answer
is a hunting license i don't i don't
know is that is that a real thing gabe
do you i have no idea this is a we've
never bought a mess this is a
a weird rule law thing i've never i well
i mean you know they're passing they're
passing laws to take away your liberty i
would imagine that maybe they'll start
passing laws to where you have to have a
hunting license to go i mean here's the
thing if they take away my guns that
means i can't i can't go and trap these
things
well you got to have an an an ar-15 for
mice
yeah
you know how fast they run
i just got to light them up yeah they're
they're they're heavily armed okay these
these mice these these days in this
country are heavily armed you need some
some real firepower to make sure they
take anyone tom and jerry you know how
creative he gets in that show you need a
giant magnet
and a huge mallet something from acme
core
okay question trivia question number two
this is another state-wide question in
texas it's illegal to swear
in front of what in front of a church
that would make sense that really would
make sense and really this thing a lot
of times probably appears in churches
during a certain ritual but the answer
here on this website which i'm sure
this website is correct it is published
on the internet so i'm sure i think this
is uber uber
so the answer is a corpse a corpse is
the answer
to question number two and i don't know
is that still is that still a thing or
is that like outdated and been repealed
why do you think even if this is real
why would you think they would make it
illegal to swear in front of a corpse
would it be like because you don't want
your dead grandma you probably because
you want to like pay respects and
swearing but i guess it depends on what
type of family you're in like maybe
swearing is the type of respect i would
give someone right damn he's an [ __ ]
yeah
you can do that yeah
look at this
look at this [ __ ] casket it is nice i
don't know i don't know why you wouldn't
be able to swear in front of a course
because they can't hear you right like
this must be a religious i don't know
are they are they really dead or they're
like going to become the undead and they
come back and like i heard you swear at
me
i heard you swear
have you ever seen have you ever seen
the ray stevens
parody song waking up with the or
sitting up with the dead have you ever
seen this it's an old country oh jesus
christ you guys are from the midwest you
aren't you've never seen race stevens
setting up with the dead
i'm sorry okay gabe where you're gonna
wait is that stephen is that steven's
spell with a v or a ph
no v ray stevens no i i don't know
either i don't know i'm only yeah
he doesn't have anything else
he doesn't own a college you elite
[ __ ] he doesn't own a college
like like like that's the thing like if
if ray stevens was ray stevens but then
he went on to be like a a college
professor and and own a college he would
have to change his [ __ ] name to ph
instead of yeah
is that is that what you're saying
it sounds like anyway you limp guards
okay um let's see another another um
here here we go in minnesota it is
illegal to tease
what type of animal and i
well again i don't know what they mean
by tees but in minnesota it is illegal
to tease what type of animal kangaroo
minnesota are there are there a lot of
are there a lot of
yeah yeah
kangaroos are that's i would make sense
right because you like you don't want to
tease a kangaroo because the kangaroos
like you know they can't fight
yeah
you will get knocked the [ __ ] out
if you just tease it in any way
you will get rushed on stage
keep my wife's diaper
[Laughter]
wait wait do you do the kangaroo action
again do it again keep my wife's name
out your mouth mike
perfect perfect perfect laning i wish i
wish kangaroo now was the correct answer
but the correct answer is skunks and it
makes sense that skunks is the answer
because in minnesota you know they
wouldn't want the whole pepe le pew
thing maybe because they think maybe the
skunk is kind of rapey is that why they
you know you think that's why they don't
don't tease him he'll get that way
yeah i think i think yeah it's like
don't tease him he's like that's his
kink he's into it that skunk's gonna
turn around and try to molest you so
yeah very well could go that way and
nobody benefits from a skunk going off
you know that's a that's not a me
problem that's a everybody around
problem i've never tried i've never you
know luckily knock on wood been uh
been skunked before
you
yeah i know there is one that lives in
the neighborhood like happy living
are like sprayed like no just like
sprayed because there is there's one
that lives like or just hangs out near
where i live and on the right night with
the good breeze it just kind of comes in
you're like
[ __ ]
but i do i do wonder
you know like does the tomato sauce
like is that isn't it like a way to like
detox yourself from the skunk smells
like you have to bathe in tomato sauce
or something like that i think that was
on jackass it's got to be real yeah yeah
i don't know i don't know if that's an
uber fact but it might be it should be
so i'll tell you how much of a hillbilly
i am um
i actually my aunt had a pet raccoon
and i've known some people had a pet
possum
and um it is illegal in missouri to
actually de-gland a skunk you can't take
the glandus gun and the reason why they
made it illegal is because a lot of
people would have pet skunks and they
would de-gland them so they wouldn't
spray people um my dad actually grew up
with a with a girl who had a pet skunk
and she would carry it everywhere in her
coat like she had the skunk in her coat
so
are they nice they're good pets then i
well i mean
maybe maybe they're like a cat i have no
idea i really i mean a wild skunk if you
corner like a possum or anything you
know not to get too hillbilly on you
here but if you corner a a raccoon or a
possum or a skunk they get really
[ __ ] pissed off like they're really
[ __ ] mad that you're cornering them
and it seems like you're going to hurt
them they're like i just wanted to
rummage through this [ __ ] over here this
trash like just leaving me man right i
mean they want to scurry off and be
scared and get the hell out of there but
if you corner you know a skunk i mean
that's why they have these thing you
know like a the possum has the nasty
teeth and a raccoon looks like a robber
you know and
but but the the skunk has the
the ar-15 of the
of of the scent world right i mean they
will they will definitely mow you down
with their scent
um next question here um speaking of of
taking women's liberty away this is a
good one
it was illegal for women to wear what in
19th century florence it was illegal for
women to wear what in 19th century
florence gabe
the shoes
it's just like a is this like a barefoot
in the kitchen type joke that you're
trying to make yeah like i don't i don't
know like i just think like well you
know i don't know what i mean it depends
on you know what class is a woman in
right like what is she allowed to wear
what is she not allowed to wear i don't
know i feel like men have been uh you
know deciding what women can do with
their bodies for many many years
so it's like why it's like listen if
you're in the house you don't need a
pair of shoes right
maybe that's the logic i don't know
i originally was going to say deodorant
but i want to choose
19th century that makes sense deodorant
totally makes sense uh brent do you have
a guess on this one do you think you
know what uh in 19th century
is it pants
very close it's address
button buttons buttons is the answer
that they have here what did they just
tie
everything because there was no zipper
back then so it was just everything had
to be tied maybe maybe gabe maybe gabe
big zipper was trying to make a trying
to make an entry into the market and
that is why
that is why with the deep state they use
the deep state to make it illegal for
women to wear buttons so that the zipper
market would take off i mean there is a
big zipper i mean i am i mean you know
you got to have a corset or whatever
yeah
yeah
tight
just imagine how inconvenient everything
would be without buttons like zippers is
one thing or velcro but if you didn't
have buttons
oh
yeah no thank you i'm out it's a lot a
lot of what is it specifically about
buttons that disturbs you it's such a
basic thing we all button something
today probably you know
yeah otherwise it'd be a drawstring i
don't know do you have a button on your
pants i i'm i'm i'm wearing i'm wearing
shorts i i i podcast now for a living i
don't wear i don't wear pants that have
butt i actually i don't have a button on
my either so
yeah you're you're wearing sweatpants
aren't you i mean i'm uh i i'm lucky
you're athletic pants let's be honest
you're athletic paints okay oh right
right
[Laughter]
no longer can they after after the
coronavirus and the pandemic can they be
called sweatpants they're athletic
because you're being
aspiring to be athletic in these pants
is that the decision there's nothing
better to lounge in than athletic wear
so
what are you wearing i'm wearing
activewear i'm very active right now
what are you doing i'm just laying on
the couch but i'm active yeah right
you're
actively
all right right
i think i'm gonna run into the kitchen
and grab another snickers and a beer
like that's the yeah that's what you're
adding
i got a lot of things going on you know
a lot of a lot of calories being burned
right now i'm being very active i'm uh
i'm anti-button
[Laughter]
i i don't know maybe there's a supreme
court case where we can make it illegal
in this country from from women wearing
buttons i mean i i'm not i wouldn't be
surprised if that's their next their
next thing that they want to outlaw
women is to get rid of buttons and only
only active athletic wear so you guys
really suck though i will say this
buttons on jeans is the outside of like
a top button but buttons whenever i'm
like i gotta buy a pair of jeans and
they're like it doesn't have a zipper
great that's what i want because the
buttons
the amount of time you spend
buttoning your pants like your jeans
like i gotta go to the bathroom oh
[ __ ] i gotta unbutton the thing am i
at the urinal or am i in the stall
trying to do this and then i'm there
taking up time trying to button it back
up and and then people like what are you
doing yeah
and i'm like no i swear so then i go
into i would totally say yes yes that's
what i'm doing yeah yeah and then i go
into the stall and someone's like oh
this guy's over here taking a [ __ ] he's
like no i'm just trying to butt my pants
back up yeah it's a whole nother what do
they think you're taking a [ __ ] standing
up because you're standing up for a long
time
who knows you know maybe that's when his
feet are backwards
this guy's gonna [ __ ] on the floor
you know
you know you guys really suck at this
trivia thing you haven't gotten one of
these one of these questions right it's
almost it's almost as if these questions
were unanswerable or something yeah
one more one more um that i got here
is uh what was hugh heckner's
jet plane named what was hugh hefner's
jet name
named
jet plane excuse me jet plane named what
was it named
steinmetz
[Music]
no br brent do you have a
no
wrong answer for both of you you really
truly do suck at this well it would be
easier it would probably be easier if i
gave you like multiple choice and like
yeah you know that would be great you
know i mean i said my answer because
that's where he went to high school
because he went to high school a little
little factoid here for people uber oh
here we go he went to high school with
my grandparents
and he was in that group of people
and so when uh
was
yeah so wait a second so he went to high
school with your grandma right you have
my grandmother yeah and my grandpa yeah
yeah well i mean don't try to make this
great
i'm just trying to say
d gabe do you have do you have dna is
there a dna test like the 23andme so
yeah it wasn't i mean look i mean we're
we'll take up you're really nervous
you're really nervous listen
answer the question gabe
i don't know if i am uh
we just called him uncle heff i don't
know you know you come over and like
give us presents and be like this is
from your uncle jeff yeah i'm sure my
grandma and him would go do some stuff
for a while they said they were in the
garden i don't know
but what i will say is they they went to
high school together
and when hugh hefner was like hey look i
i need i i'm asking for a loan from
people like an investment when he was
originally starting out he came to them
and i think it was five thousand dollars
but at the time that was
a lot of money right it's a lot of
branding right now yeah yeah it's a lot
of money now yeah right and back then
right and so i think the timeline was it
was started in 1953 my grandpa served in
the korean war he came back didn't have
the money
they were you know thinking about
starting a family in a few years
and then they're like can't do it and
here i am you know so so it's too bad
gabe because the plane that you would
own or would have owned a park i just
love i googled it i googled it can i say
it and maybe let's see yes
gabe can edit it gabe can edit it in and
yeah
the big bunny it is the big bunny see
ding ding ding see here that makes sense
that makes sense
here's the thing is that these questions
are now validated and all the things
that we have said now for this trivia
are absolutely 100 true and you cannot
you cannot dispute them because the
google machine right google machine said
so right brent is that is that that's
true
one's validated that means the rest of
them
i mean all all of the facts that were
said
in this video must be facts because one
of them
the internet says is true in the google
machine where where did you find it on
google by the way did you just google it
hugh hefner jet
is it what website is it is it from the
same website that i'm looking at no i'm
just kidding
addweek.com
was the top response
uh hollywood reporter i think there's a
bunch of them and there's pictures of
it says welcome hef big bunny on there
so it's a very famously named plane and
gabe see you could have
you could have you if if you if there
would have been 23 of me way back when
there may have been a time where you
would have owned a portion
i know i could be i could be i could be
doing this podcast from the jet the big
bunny
but how many times people of like hey
let me get five grand for this idea and
then people be like yeah we never saw
that guy again
i mean it's just crazy
yeah they're like listen i just need
five grand this one time i swear i swear
i've got an idea it's gonna make it's
gonna make so much money and you're like
is this a pyramid scheme yeah what's
going on here well it's funny that you
say that because that's why i asked you
guys here uh because
five thousand dollars from both of you
does have anything to do with
pornography because if so i'm in i'm in
if it is okay yes it does
thanks thanks for playing trivia
everyone stick around after the after
the music we'll be right back thanks for
playing the trivia with us
[Music]
because i was like is it 40 000 and i
was like that's a
[ __ ] ton of money back then
it's
a thousand dollars
that his mother gave him but i think
when i originally read about it it was
the equivalent
of forty thousand like in today's money
oh i should be 40
but yeah she
she funded in part by a thousand dollar
so wait a second he was asking your
grandpa
he was he was boning your grandma in the
garden and asking grandpa for five
thousand dollars i can't wait till my
mom hears this episode
did your mom watch the show
uh maybe sometimes
now she won't know yeah
i don't know
he's making fun of her um you brought it
up i didn't bring it i know i know i
just thought hey i'll make it relatable
i'll tell you a little bit a little
factoid here
yeah well the thing is i don't know who
the other investors were but according
to what i've read online it just has
other like them his mom put in a
thousand dollars and then his other like
associates put in money so i don't know
how much they were
going for or what exactly but so his
buddies that he partied with on the
weekends in high school they put in the
other exactly yeah yeah okay well
because he needed five grand he needed
five grand brent do you have any let's
let's plug your let's plug all your
stuff get give me where to find
everyone out there tell everyone out
there tell the audience where to find
brett there hewn's um not only his
stand-up dates but all his content and
where you can follow him we want to get
you some subscribers if you don't
already have the people that we're
listening to i'm sure our fans you know
the venn diagram is you know pretty
pretty circle right it's a circle here
uh brent comedy.com for all my stuff all
the links to my social media
uh if there's a social media i'm
probably on it so you can just search my
name
and um yeah are you on true social are
you on twitch i'm on now i was like hey
i just can't do
i'm not even gonna put the effort into
that so i just can't do it oh it's gross
over there it's a swamp and it's all
fake sure and tony gets censored any
time he posts yeah i posted something
and it was i posted a video that i cut
together of jd vance and and donald
trump calling him jd mandel and it got
censored
immediately like before it was even up
uh it was the truth right well you know
you know that happens that happens yeah
yeah um yeah i'm on all that stuff and
brentcomedy.com and uh
i'm always posting a new stand-up tour
date so i might come to your uh your
town if you live in a uh you're not from
around here town maybe or a big city so
where's your where's your next show
where's your next show i don't even know
i i know for sure i am in uh louisville
kentucky at a place called planet of the
tapes
um it's a comedy club with a video store
in the back like a hugh hefner type
video store or just maybe is it oh okay
yeah i just need five thousand dollars
[Laughter]
i'm talking about i think i'm gonna
start so right yeah oh okay okay
this isn't a thing yet it may be no you
yeah no i've seen that you you you play
there a lot that must be a favorite
place of yours to yeah one of my
favorites and i'll be in detroit
michigan uh june 30th through july 2nd
at the comedy castle that's one of my
favorite uh places to perform and
earlier than that june 11th i will be at
the funny farm in youngstown ohio so if
you're in like the cleveland area i
think that's close i don't know but uh
yeah all my dates are breakcomedy.com
fantastic fantastic awesome man i really
appreciate you joining us and and
breaking down uh some of your comedy i
know sometimes you know uh the content
creators and comics and comedians they
produce this they put all their hard
work a lot of people think oh you're
just grabbing your phone and just just
screwing around and sometimes it's that
way but you know you do put a lot of
thought and effort um into your videos
and into your comedy and and everyone go
if if brent is in your area go check him
out uh his stand up it is completely
different than his than his videos i i
do have a special comment out i don't
know when it's not done and i don't know
where it will be
uh so that's
what you have you have already you'll be
on the lookout yeah it's in the can and
the special will be called what on flat
earth so everyone everyone keep uh
you're going to want to go to rent
social media because i'm sure i'm sure
eventually he'll put some sort of
announcement you know like three months
after it's aired or something
he'll put an announcement out there for
when is special and where it airs so be
looking for that on his social media
brent thank you thank you for joining us
come back any time my friend come back
on the live show where we can create
some some live you want to if you want
to come back as one of the you know as a
truck character yeah yeah i i mean gabe
gabe may or may not have been uh jd
bandel on our show today so uh we got
the exclusive interview of jd mandel um
and got
jd mandel broke a lot of news today on
our show so go check that episode out
too ed brent thank you for joining us
and stick around everybody we will be
right back right after this break